new record shattering numbers on the
migrant surge at the southern border as
we ring in this new year Customs and
Border Protection sources are telling
Fox News that agents encountered more
than
302,000 migrants in December alone and
more than
785,000 since October 1st marking the
highest monthly and quarterly totals on
record let's bring in Robert omon former
US Marshal in Al Paso Texas here we are
are on the cusp of a new year thank you
for giving us a little bit of your time
on this weekend when we're looking ahead
to 2024 do you see anything on this
issue
changing no I I I don't you know uh it's
really unbelievable what's going on on
the Southwest border and and for me what
makes it even more unbelievable is that
several weeks ago the director of the
FBI came out and issued warnings about
increased threats about terrorism
occurring in the United States uh and as
you have reported already several
terrorists from the watch lft terrorism
watch lft have been apprehended in the
Border trying to come into United States
so I don't know what it's going to take
for us to take border patrol excuse me
border security um seriously and secure
the Border I got to be honest with you I
was bracing myself for a terrorist
attack Christmas and New Year thankfully
that didn't happen uh but I think these
terrorists are already in the United
States they're planning a terrorist
attack and they're going to do it when
we least expected and then that'll be
the wakeup call when finally we'll
secure the borders I just don't
understand uh what's going on I'm very
I'm very worried about the situation on
our border right now yeah Texas has
understandably been unable to sustain
this big influx and and now many of
these migrants have been sent to other
cities around the country some of these
Sanctuary cities were Democratic Mayors
and governors in these blue states are
standing up and saying to the federal
government we need help we need you to
take action is that the type of
political pressure that is going to turn
the tide as far as the administration is
concerned the type of pressure that
we've seen really increasing in recent
months yeah that's exactly what it's
going to take and where were we the
excuse me where were these Mayors and
governors before they felt the impact uh
in their own cities and their states the
border cities have been feeling this
impact for some time now and now that
they're impacted by this now they're
complaining so that's exactly why
Governor Abbott is doing what he's doing
this is a result of the frustration and
uh and just really a hopeless situation
so he's doing all he can and all these
border states are doing all they can so
that that is my my my thoughts on that
Texas Congressman Tony Gonzalez he
represents by the way the uh State's
23rd congressional district that's the
largest stretch of Border territory of
any congressional district had this to
say on Fox News
Sunday I believe in legal immigration I
believe most of America believes in
legal immigration but what we're seeing
is not that this is chaos and so enough
is enough it's time to deport those that
illegally come into the United States
and President Biden can either do that
or he can watch and lose and watch the
next president uh enforce those policies
that are on the books pointing out there
that 2024 is an election year this is an
election issue it's something the voters
care about is that going to be a wakeup
call yes it it definitely is and because
it is an election year that's why we're
seeing uh more activity uh from our
Administration that's why uh we saw uh
the secretary Homeland Security
Secretary of State have a meeting with
President over that's why myor is going
to the Border where were all these
meetings uh in Mexico and On the Border
where were all these meetings before the
election time so this is just a result
of of politics and that's been the
problem all along is people are too busy
trying to find political solutions for
this problem and we don't need a
political solution we need a real
solution we're talking about people's
lives that Stakes here a lot of these
migrants trying to come into the
greatest country in the world are dying
trying to do that but you don't hear
those stories you just hear people
saying come on in everybody's welcome
that it's not that easy and uh and
here's the other thing is that even if
we were going to secure the Border today
I think too much damage has already been
done we have a lot of terrorists that
have come into United States and another
concern is going to be all these gotway
we don't know anything about them and
there's no doubt in my mind a lot of
them are going to be criminals dangerous
criminal fugitives from their country so
it's very alarming yeah a lot of
questions about what 2024 May hold we
really appreciate your insights Happy
New Year to you thanks for coming
on Happy New Year to you and everyone at
FX thank you mik I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilm me and I'm Angley aart and click
here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analys
is